[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY HYLTON: I'm really
pleased to have Dr. Joy Rankin
here today to talk
about her new book,
"A People's History of
Computing in the United States,"
if I got that right.
JOY LISI RANKIN: Yes, you did.
JEREMY HYLTON: And I sort of
discovered the book, you know,
browsing on the web.
And, you know, it
talked about sort
of early computing experiences.
And I really
connected with BASIC,
which is going to come
up a lot in the book.
I started programming in
BASIC and home computer
when I was a kid,
and really enjoyed
a book called "101
Basic Computer Games"
that were very simple games.
And it's interesting
that as I became
a professional
programmer, I mostly
spent talking about how much I
didn't really approve of BASIC.
It was not a serious
language, right?
But, you know, in thinking
about it and reading the book,
I came to remember how
much fun it was and how--
like how you turned
on a computer
and there was BASIC in
front of you, right?
Like, you know, you immediately
got the interpreter prompt,
and that was pretty amazing.
And I thought the message
of the book lined up so well
with the three
respects we're trying
to think about it at Google.
One, respect the user,
since this is really
all about letting users program
the computer and interact
with it more directly.
And I thought this book was
particularly interesting
when we think about
respecting the opportunity.
Because we have a
big business that
sells computing to consumers.
You know, we either pay through
ads or through the cloud
computing business.
And that's kind of intention--
or, you know, the
business relationship
is a little bit in tension
with empowering people
to create whatever they want.
Now, clearly cloud sort
of supports that, as well.
But the-- I think the
early idea of search
was to make the web
more powerful, right?
That as the web got
better, Google got better.
And as Google got better we
made the web better for people.
And I think there's a little
bit of a tension between that
and running a large corporation
and then a profitable business.
And I thought some of the
stories you had to tell really
helped remind us of how
many people are creators
and how much creativity we
can unlock when we really
think about them and
the opportunities we
create for them.
So that's why I was so excited
to have you come and talk
about this book.
So Dr. Rankin is a historian,
but in chatting with her today,
I found out she was also
a math major at Dartmouth.
She has written
some crypto code.
So I think she brings a
really interesting perspective
to the whole story.
So let me turn it over to her.
JOY LISI RANKIN: Thank you,
Jeremy, for that introduction,
and thank you all
for being here today.
I am so excited to have the
opportunity to speak with you
and speak with Google.
I am just going
to jump right in.
JEREMY HYLTON: Switch
to that slide for you.
JOY LISI RANKIN: All right.
So in 1958, Tom Kurtz wanted
to run a computer program.
Here is Tom Kurtz circa 1958.
So to do this, to run
his computer program,
he woke early one morning
and traveled about five miles
from his home in
Hanover, New Hampshire
to White River
Junction, Vermont.
He carried with him a steel
box that looked like this one.
And when he got to White
River Junction, Vermont,
he boarded the 620
morning train to Boston.
At Boston, he trades
the train for a taxi
to get to the computer
center at MIT.
Finally, finally, at
MIT's computer center,
he opens the box that
he carries with him,
and it contains hundreds
of cardboard cards.
So some of those cards, very
carefully ordered and wrapped
with an elastic band,
are his computer program.
Other cards contain the
programs of his colleagues
at Dartmouth College, where
he is a professor in the math
department.
So Dartmouth is a small
liberal arts college.
During the 1950s, it doesn't
have its own computer,
so the Dartmouth professors used
the computing resources at MIT.
So Kurtz hands his
stack of punch cards
over to the operator at the MIT
computer center and walks away.
Hours later, at
the end of the day,
he goes back to the computer
center to pick up his cards
and pick up the very
precious printout results
of his computer program.
And he gets on the train back
home, and he sees, of course,
some error messages.
What does this mean?
Well, it means he's going to
have to revise his program,
re-punch the cards, and repeat
this process all over again two
weeks later.
So I love starting
with this story
because it shows that individual
access to computing in 1958
was so rare and so valuable that
Tom Kurtz was willing to spend
a whole day to receive a few
minutes, maybe a few seconds,
of access to computing,
and it also really shows
Tom's perspective as a user.
So this brings me
to my research.
The question that
guides my research
is, what does it mean to
write histories of computing
and of technology
from the user up?
My book, "A People's History
of Computing in the United
States," answers that question.
The people in this
"People's History"
are students and
educators, people
like Tom Kurtz who built
and used academic computing
networks during the
1960s and the 1970s.
So mine is a history
of our digital age
that really emphasizes
creativity and collaboration
and community.
So for the next
15 minutes or so,
I'm going to tell you how Kurtz
and thousands of other students
and educators built a
computing network that spanned
New England during the 1960s.
And I want to show you how
computing was interwoven
in their daily lives.
It was part of their status,
their sports, their dates,
their dating, and their gaming.
And finally, I will conclude
with an opportunity.
So all that time on the
train got Kurtz to thinking,
there has to be a
better way to do this.
And a few years after
that 1958 train ride,
he proposed a better
way of computing
to a fellow math professor
at Dartmouth, John Kemeny.
And Kurtz pitched
three related ideas.
First, all students
at the college
should have access to computing.
And this is important.
Not just the scientists
or the engineers
or the mathematicians,
but everyone, regardless
of what they were studying.
He also advocated
that computing should
be free for the students,
not something they
would have to pay for.
And finally, he thought
the first two things
could be accomplished by
a then mode of computing
known as time-sharing.
So what's time-sharing?
Time-sharing is a
form of computing
in which multiple
terminals, multiple users
are simultaneously connected
to a single mainframe computer.
It's a network because they're
connected by phone lines.
So not necessarily a network
like we think of today,
but all of those
terminals can still
communicate with each
other via the mainframe.
The terminals are
connected to the mainframe
by long distance phone
lines or local phone lines,
as the case may be, and the
terminals look like this.
And so they're teletype writers,
or teletypes, originally used
for telegraphy, then
used for computing,
and like an old
fashioned typewriter
with a printer attached.
So users would enter
their programs,
see them sort of printed
out, and then, the computer
would communicate
back to the user
by printing out program
results on the teletype writer.
So what this means
is an individual user
is able to write and debug a
program in minutes, not hours
or weeks.
So when Kurtz and Kemeny seek
funding for their network, what
they emphasize is that at most
other university computing
centers during the
1960s, those universities
are focused on maximizing the
resources of the computer.
Computers-- very
large, very expensive.
The most efficient
thing and do is
to keep them running
as much as possible,
but that doesn't
do a lot of good
for the people
using the computers.
Instead, Kemeny
and Kurtz say, we
want to build a
network that will
be most convenient for the user
to enable as much creativity
and productivity as
possible for those users
rather than maximizing the
efficiency of the computer.
They get their funding.
Kurtz writes a series of
memos to guide the development
efforts.
And at this point, I
should say this network
is programmed and
developed by Dartmouth
undergraduate students.
And Kurtz specifies--
and this is a quote--
"in all cases where there is
a choice between simplicity
and efficiency,
simplicity is chosen.
Every effort will be
made to design a system
convenient for the user."
So I love this because clearly,
this is respect for the user.
This is what it looks like for
Kemeny and Kurtz circa 1963.
And at this point,
I'm just going
to say that the Dartmouth
system, the network,
was wildly popular.
It was implemented in 1964.
By 1968, on campus,
80% of the students
are regularly using the network.
They know BASIC.
They program comfortably.
And 40% of the
faculty are regularly
using the network and BASIC.
But-- and this is
equally important--
the sort of generic idea,
just the word, "user"
on the Dartmouth network
shows that that word
masked social and
cultural hierarchies
and norms and expectations,
especially around gender.
So Kemeny and Kurtz designed
their time-sharing network
because they believed that their
students, who were all men--
during the 1960s, Dartmouth
is still men only as
an undergraduate institution.
And during the 1960s,
Dartmouth is almost exclusively
white as an institution--
that those white men would
be the future leaders
of the United States.
And they thought
that computing was
essential to their future
leadership of the United
States.
They also envisioned
computing as an equalizer
among their students, that
all of the students having
that access for free
would be something
of an equal opportunity.
But the students
saw it differently.
The students who had
programmed the network
and continued to
develop and maintain it
really created a space and
hierarchy for themselves
based on their familiarity
with the system.
So they mocked their peers
who thought of the teletypes
as computers or complained
if a teletype wasn't
working that the
computer wasn't working.
And they played practical
jokes, substituting
strings of meaningless text
into the output of a program
that somebody had spent
hours or days writing.
These programmer and
student peers, however,
were united in their
enthusiasm for football
played on the field
and on the network.
So football-- to say
that football dominated
Dartmouth's culture
during the 1960s
is a bit of an understatement.
Dartmouth won the Ivy League
Championship several times,
and really, the
campus and football
went hand-in-hand as cultures.
And there were several
versions of football.
FTBALL like this was one of them
that were developed and played
on the network, including
a multiplayer version.
So the popularity of the
football on the network
really mirrored the celebration
of this very masculine, macho
sport on campus.
The football games also provided
an opportunity from women
from nearby all women's
colleges to travel to Hanover
to socialize with
the Dartmouth men,
and many men recalled that
they brought their deeds
to the campus computing centers
before or after the games
to show off their
computing prowess
or show off their
gaming expertise,
even though several of
those women's colleges
were also part of the
Dartmouth network, which
meant the women themselves
were also computing, as well.
So in the course
of my research, I
was repeatedly struck by how
many Dartmouth men wanted
to tell me and did tell
me stories about computing
in connection with dating
and how they really
were reinforcing existing gender
roles with their computing.
So one told me he
used the teletype
to print out this huge
banner that said "HEY,
GIRL"-- in all caps.
"HEY, GIRL, I MISS YOU."
And he rolled up the huge banner
and put it in a poster tube
and mailed it to
his then girlfriend.
He was attending
college in New York.
And now, they've been
married for almost 50 years.
And this is one example.
Like, I'm happy to give
you more during the Q&A.
But what do I mean
by gender roles here?
So remember, we're
talking the 1960s.
The Cold War nuclear
family was the norm.
Right, this idea that there
is a breadwinner father
and a domestic mother staying at
home and some kids in suburbia.
And we can see this
even with computing.
So John Kemeny goes on to become
president of Dartmouth College,
and in 1966, the college
is dedicating its brand
new computing center.
And he gives a keynote speech
at the dedication and he
talks about how great
it will be when everyone
has terminals in their homes.
At this point, some
faculty already
have terminals in their
homes as part of the network.
And he talks about housewives
using the terminals
to do things like
program their chores
and plan balanced diets and
meals for their families
and do their shopping online.
And those are the--
that's the way that he
sees women using computing.
But while he is talking about
housewives using computing
to prepare balanced
meals, there are
women working at
Dartmouth in that computer
center in key roles.
There is a disconnect there.
So Janet Price, Diane
Hills, Diane Mather,
they're all doing various kinds
of applications programming,
coding.
Nancy Broadhead
manages user services.
The two Dianes are also
managing the software library.
And the examples go on.
I bring this up because
these women were not
exceptions to the norm,
but rather represented
the range of
possibilities for women
doing professional computing in
the United States in the 1960s.
And, as I mentioned,
many of the college women
themselves had
access to computing
at their own colleges.
They, too, were doing
this personal computing,
this social networking
through the Dartmouth network.
During the 1960s, the
network encompassed
tens of colleges
and high schools
from Connecticut to Maine.
So this is a map of about
20 of the high schools
that were connected to the
network during the 1960s.
Some were in very poor
rural farming communities.
Others were elite, prestigious,
affluent boarding schools.
A huge range.
The students, however,
everywhere, they
loved the network.
They loved programming
and creating and BASIC.
They kept their teletypes
running 12 hours a day,
six days a week.
Some of them even
woke up at 4 o'clock
in the morning-- high schoolers.
Like, high schoolers waking
up at 4 o'clock voluntarily
just because they want to
get on the network and that's
when they can do it.
They created a multitude of
imaginative games and programs.
These are just some
of the examples.
High school newspaper layout,
battleship, bowling, and more.
But, once again, this attempt
to sort of provide equal access,
equal opportunities
through computing,
it didn't quite
pan out that way.
Why?
Well, boys and young
men had much more access
to the Dartmouth
network than girls.
So during the 1960s, every
single private school
that was connected to the
network was boys only.
And those private schools had
72 hours of teletype access
each week, compared to the
40 hours for public schools.
So boys at private schools have
almost double the access time,
the network time, being shared
compared with public school
boys and girls.
And the boys are often
in sort of newsletters
about the program, reports.
The boys are more often
recognized for their programs,
even though girls are still
writing these programs,
as well.
So again, keep in
mind the 1960s.
Although career expectations
and educational opportunities
for girls and women would change
dramatically in the next decade
during the 1960s, most
of the girls attending
these public schools
in New England
were expected to be
homemakers and to marry young.
And at the time,
high school boys
were enrolling in many more math
and science classes than girls,
and the girls were just not
encouraged in computing,
even if they were interested.
But make no mistake, they
were still computing.
So, for example,
13-year-old Julia Hawthorne
wrote a game of
checkers in BASIC,
and there are more examples.
It's just that the
girls and women were not
recognized or supported as
much as the boys and men,
and the Cold War
gender norms helped
erase their contributions.
So to us now, 50 years
later, all of this
seems a little bit remarkable.
So Tom Kurtz and John
Kemeny, as I said,
they envisioned computing
as an equalizer.
I think they were trying to
implement a version of respect
each other with this idea
of computing for all,
but that's not how it played out
because society was not equal,
right?
There are different
expectations,
we can clearly see, for boys
and girls, men and women,
and different levels
of access and resources
and recognition for
everyone involved.
So here, I see the
opportunity to recognize
that computing was not divorced
from the culture in which it
arose.
Kemeny and Kurtz
and their students,
they built the network with
people like themselves in mind.
And ditto for all
of the students
who created BASIC programs.
They were thinking about
themselves and their friends.
And that is absolutely
understandable,
but it also points to the
fact that technology is not
a thing apart from society.
Talking about tech people or
separating out tech companies,
that's a false dichotomy
because it's always
people who are creating,
who are inventing,
who are problem solving
and moonshotting.
And it's almost
always that they're
doing those things with
other people in mind,
even if that's not
explicitly stated.
And often, still, the people who
aren't recognized as techie--
the girls writing
the BASIC programs,
teachers cultivating
computing communities,
the women behind the scenes at
Dartmouth's computer center--
they're still doing
crucial technological work.
So today, all too often, we
talk about things, right?
We talk about our computers
and our devices, the internet,
the web, the algorithm.
And that makes all
of those things
seem disconnected from
us, from the people who
create them and use
them and transform them.
So there is the opportunity.
By focusing on computing
rather than computers,
we gain a completely different
picture of technology.
We listen for and hear the
voices not usually heard,
and we search for
and find the stories
that have been overlooked or
never told in the first place.
And we remember that technology
has always been about people.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY HYLTON: We'll switch
you back to the local camera.
JOY LISI RANKIN: All right.
JEREMY HYLTON: And let's see.
I think we need--
we need a second
microphone, probably.
Do we have a second microphone?
OK.
JOY LISI RANKIN:
Oh, look at that.
JEREMY HYLTON: And I will--
I'll get some notes.
So I prepared a few questions.
We would, of course, love
to have your questions, too.
SPEAKER: So let's
see if we can control
the camera a little bit.
JEREMY HYLTON: I'll start
with a couple of mine
since I had a little time to
think in advance about them.
And, you know, if anyone
does want to ask a question,
just feel free to jump in.
I guess-- I mean, you
talked a lot about gender
and you mentioned earlier
how we do, I guess,
tend to forget about the role of
women in computing in the 60s.
So, for example, my advisor
got his start working on CTSS
and then went on
to work on Multics,
and so I've read a
bunch of those papers,
but it actually wasn't until I
read your book that I realized
that I think the second author
on the CTSS paper was a woman,
Marjorie.
Everyone used
initials back then,
so I only ever recognized
her by her last name, right?
And so yeah, that was a
little invisible to me.
You talk about
how it's connected
to people I feel sometimes
like society and culture has
moved farther ahead than
maybe computing has, right?
So we have, I
think, more problems
with equity in the industry
than we do in society at large.
Like, I wonder if you think
that's fair or, you know,
if there's a reason
for that, right?
Is it that somehow,
computing didn't keep up
with the rest of society?
Usually, you think of
computing being ahead, right?
JOY LISI RANKIN:
Yeah, I actually--
I feel like what I'm about
to say sounds pessimistic,
but I think right now at
this moment, in some ways--
in this cultural
moment-- society
is maybe about where
sort of technology is
and that they're inseparable.
I was listening to a
podcast the other day,
and one of the speakers
said that in technology,
and STEM more broadly, there's
not a pipeline problem.
It's not about getting women
in because there have always
been women doing science and
technology and computing.
It's a gender problem.
It's sort of how we think about
what is normal and expected
of men, of women, not
just in culture broadly,
but in particular cases.
Part of why I love
the Dartmouth case
is because you really see this
creation of masculine computing
around football, around
playing computing pranks,
around the fact that
there are women working
in all sorts of ways in tech.
And still, the
college president is
talking about women doing
their grocery shopping.
So I think there is work to
be done in tech and in society
and really thinking about
the kinds of cultures
or micro cultures, maybe,
corporate cultures, and how
they both mirror what's
happening in society,
as well as how they might be a
room to sort of steer and shift
changes in society, as well.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
Maybe also mention as
set up to this question,
the book talks about more
than Dartmouth and BASIC.
JOY LISI RANKIN: Yes.
JEREMY HYLTON: And
I thought that's
really fascinating to see sort
of the range of early computer
networks and what
they were like.
So there was a--
there's this great
network that Illinois
built around a computer
with like a plasma
display and a touch screen.
JOY LISI RANKIN: By 1975.
JEREMY HYLTON: Right.
Yeah.
Which was really impressive.
And a network in
Minnesota that was
run by the state for all
the schools in the state.
And I guess I was curious
to what extent did you
explore how maybe the gender
roles were different in some
of those places?
I know when you talk about
Illinois in the book,
the one example you use of sort
of the teaching software that's
developed was a woman
developing coursework
for nursing students.
I guess she happened
to be the husband
of the creator of the partner
of the creator of the system.
But was that different
by virtue of the nature
of what it was used for in the
student population, or not?
JOY LISI RANKIN: I
think it's the same sort
of unusual juxtaposition
of the fact
that-- so this network centered
at the University of Illinois
called PLATO, originally, it
starts as a network that's
focused on education, like
computer assisted instruction.
And so in trying to
develop this system,
they're working with
men and women experts
from all sorts of
different fields.
And as a result, you
end up with people
like Maryann Bitzer,
who is creating
nursing education for her
students, but as a result,
also becoming she is
doing technological work.
There's another
woman, Valarie Lamont,
who actually creates
a program that's
related to environmental
pollution in Urbana-Champaign.
And again, she's a
political scientist,
but doing this technological
communicative work.
And so I think what
we see with PLATO--
and I talk about this a bit
in the book-- is that there
is a space for these women
to sort of do things that
are defying the sort of cultural
norm, but at the same time,
the network itself and the way
that it's spoken about more
broadly in society sort of does
things like reinforce gender
norms.
So, for instance, it's
an amazing resource.
There are four years of
their notes files, which
were like their digital bulletin
board, and they preserved them.
And you can go
online and sort of
read through four years
of people's interactions
on a message board.
And those clearly
show sort of women
complaining about harassment.
Like, women who are working
on the system who are experts,
they're treated
differently than the men.
So it's this push and
pull, this tension
of, ah, we've got a
space for women to do
the technological work,
but it's not recognized,
and they're often, because
of the culture, sort of--
not even sort of, they are.
They're harassed.
They are marginalized.
They're not recognized.
JEREMY HYLTON: Right.
Yeah, I guess the kind
of mix of aggressions
and microaggressions that
I know my colleagues here
face when we're
developing software today.
So I guess, yeah, it turned
out to be a little sad
that the same sort
of gender stereotypes
continue to play out today.
You know, I think we have
more awareness today,
so maybe we can do better, but
I don't know that we're actually
doing a lot better yet.
JOY LISI RANKIN: I don't
mean-- you know, today, I
think it sort of plays out
in media representations
of-- and I talk about
this a bit in my book--
the sort of Silicon
Valley mythology
or the sort of idea
that like all technology
is created by a few white guys.
And everyone in this room,
I'm sure everyone in Google,
knows that's not the case.
You're all living and
breathing evidence of that.
But still, sort of I
think in media coverage,
popular culture, it's a
still a different idea,
and it's one that kind
of privileges, you know,
pale males.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
Yeah.
I also wanted to
ask a little bit
about this notion of
computing citizenship
that you talk about, which I
thought was pretty interesting.
And it played out in
all of the places.
I guess at Dartmouth, it was
about being a good user, right,
and sharing things, but
not using too much space
for your programs that
were not worth sharing.
And you sort of contrast
that with the citizenship
and community with sort
of a consumer culture
that maybe came
with a PC, right?
Now, we want to sell
a PC into your home.
It's a thing you buy, and it
comes with software on it,
but it doesn't have
the same sharing.
And maybe you could say a
little bit more about that idea.
JOY LISI RANKIN: So when I was
on the journey of researching
and writing this
book, I really--
sort of thinking
from the user up.
For a while, I struggled
because I was like, oh.
Very quickly, it
became clear to me,
like, these aren't just users.
They are.
They're writing software.
They're creating games.
They're figuring out how to do
social networking in the 1960s.
And I debated, like, am I
going to call them authors?
You know, they're writing.
They're coding.
Are they programmers?
Are they makers?
And none of that seemed right.
And over the course
of my writing,
I realized, well,
what's essential is
they're all part of
these communities,
and those communities, they're
focused on collaboration.
And sort of at their
most ideal, there
is this idea of computing
for the public good,
computing as a
collective resource.
And so I thought of the idea
of computing citizenship
as a way to say they are
citizens of these computing
communities.
They are participating.
And it's not a political
scientist's idea
of citizenship,
although, in some ways,
they're closely related in
terms of who is recognized,
who is supported, who gets
a voice in the network
and on the network.
And so when I started thinking
about citizenship as a way
to talk about their
participation,
and also, I should
say, to emphasize
all of the public
institutions that underwrote
all of this networking, right?
They are local and state
and federal governments.
The National Science
Foundation, colleges,
and public universities,
they're all pouring money
into these computing networks.
So here's another way that sort
of citizenship comes into play.
Well, over the
course of the 1980s,
and really, with
the introduction
of personal computers
or home computers,
no more is there
this idea of like,
oh, computing might
be something we
have as a public utility, which
there was very much this idea
that there was going to
be a public computing
utility in the 1960s or 1970s.
And instead, it became
this idea of no,
everyone is going to
go out and they're
going to buy a computer.
They're going to buy a device.
They're going to buy software.
Whereas in the 60s and 70s, the
communities I'm talking about
are saying, "No, no,
we share our software.
We share our BASIC.
Like, BASIC is freely
available to whoever wants it.
We publish BASIC programs.
We circulate them."
And so to me, I saw--
sort of it's a foreclosure
of opportunity,
this shift from
saying, "Computing
could be for the public good.
It could be a public utility.
It could be regulated
by the government
for better or perhaps for
worse" to this idea of "No, no.
Everyone should go buy a
computer, buy a device,
buy some software."
That limits things.
JEREMY HYLTON: Right,
it certainly makes
the distribution of
computing less equal, right?
Because, you know, you
need to have the affluence
to afford to go buy
a computer, right?
JOY LISI RANKIN: Yes.
JEREMY HYLTON: And if you want
to connect to someone else,
you have to pay yourself
for the network access.
I was struck by how expensive
it was to be part of a network,
and that was actually
mostly telephone charges.
And you talked about how the
state of Minnesota, like,
pooled its resources,
and they were
able to negotiate with the
telephone company for better
rates and better technology.
JOY LISI RANKIN: And, I mean,
I love the Minnesota case.
So Minnesota has a
statewide computing network
that's built sort of
between 1965 and 1975.
And they're very
explicit in saying,
we're going to build this
as a public institution
to provide equality of access
not just for people in the Twin
Cities suburbs, but for
people in rural areas,
for students who are
in less affluent areas.
And they use their weight
as the state government
to do things like negotiate
better phone line rates
and negotiate lower
costs so that it really
does become a public good.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
So networking is more
widely available today.
JOY LISI RANKIN: Yes, it is.
JEREMY HYLTON: And the
cost of the devices
is lower, although a high end
smartphone is probably $1,000
these days, so it's still
not very equal access.
But, I mean, do you think
that notion of citizenship
still is one we should
be thinking about today?
I mean, right now, you are a
consumer of social networking
apps, and you don't have a whole
lot of control over it, right?
You know, would it be better
if there were more programmers,
more citizens?
JOY LISI RANKIN:
I absolutely think
citizenship is
something we should
be thinking about precisely
because we are consumers.
I mean, so much of the
social media that we consume
or so many of the apps
are made by corporations
that are out to make money,
not out to do the public good.
And those aren't necessarily
mutually exclusive,
but it's a reminder that
if you have a company that
is looking after
its bottom line,
that's the bottom line, not the
people who are using the apps
or using the platform
or whatever it is.
So I absolutely think
competing citizenship
is relevant to sort
of reimagine where
do we want our very much
digital networked world to go.
What would the conversations
around what we hope look like,
and how can the past
inform us sort of
in what we might want to
change and what we really
liked about what things looked
like in the 1960s and 1970s?
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
I tried to think what
version of programming
is available to kids today.
I've wondered, like
Minecraft is probably
the closest they get to
creating things, right?
I don't know how widespread
otherwise for kids
actual creating of things is.
JOY LISI RANKIN: I
mean, I think there
are some pushes to
sort of get kids back
into coding and programming.
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
JOY LISI RANKIN:
But I think, too,
with anything like that, there's
still the same caution of,
well, how are our sort
of societal expectations
around do we encourage
the boys more than girls,
or sort of how do these things
play out at the same time?
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
I have one more
question I thought
I would ask, and then
try to open it up
to audience questions.
So you talked about a
lot of different sort
of early computing networks
and systems and users,
and it seemed like you had a
call at the end of the book
that your list was
not exhaustive, right?
It's not like you--
like, you have other areas
that you've heard about
or you think would be really
interesting for someone
to investigate more.
JOY LISI RANKIN: Yes.
Yes.
So other people,
other historians,
other communications
and media scholars,
whoever, my book basically
ends right around 1980.
And I think sort of the
1980s into the early 1990s
is another rich,
amazing time to say,
all these people were
buying personal computers
and there were so many
computers in schools.
If we wrote those
histories from the user up,
what would they look like?
Similarly, we know a
bit about the WELL.
Well, there was a
New York City version
of that called Echo, East
Coast Hang Out, which
was a huge online bulletin board
system during the 80s and 90s,
another great source to look at.
Like, what's happening?
Sort of as more
people are networked,
what does that look like?
Yeah, there's, I
think, a whole world
and a whole case of
the 80s and early 90s,
and not just in
the United States.
This is the other thing
that I am excited about.
Some of my colleagues
are writing right now
histories of networks
in the Soviet Union
or networks in China,
these kinds of things.
And I think all of those are
important to help us understand
that the United States
isn't necessarily
the isolated, unparalleled case,
but what are the similarities
and differences?
JEREMY HYLTON: Yeah.
All right.
Thanks.
So anyone else want
to ask some questions?
We can [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for your time.
I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit more
about where this
particular work fits
into your professional
interests or your personal story
or sort of how you came to be
to want to write this book and--
JOY LISI RANKIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --put these
things together right now.
JOY LISI RANKIN: Yeah.
I love that question.
So I was actually telling
Jeremy this a little bit before.
I am maybe an atypical
historian in that I
was a math major at Dartmouth.
I was also a history major.
And after college, I
worked for almost a decade
at companies that
involve technology
and education or
launching programs that
had to do with education
and technology.
And every single time,
every single place, we'd
sort of roll something out
and watch what-- you know,
we called them the users.
Like, what are they going to do?
And it was never
what we expected
and it was always
creative and surprising,
and sometimes, infuriating.
And it was something
that at the time,
I was like, this is not
at all what I expected.
People are doing things
very differently,
and in amazing often social
ways that we hadn't planned on.
And so when I finally--
sort of my path
meandered and I said,
it's time for me to
go to grad school.
You're going to pay me to
do this, to read and write.
Yes, please.
Sign me up.
And I studied the history
of science and technology.
And when it came time to pick a
project or look for a project,
I was reminded that as an
undergraduate at Dartmouth--
I was an undergrad at
Dartmouth in the 90s--
we had this vibrant
computing culture of email.
I never picked up the phone.
I had other friends who
were like, what's email?
And I was like, email is great.
Like, I mean, right?
How can I tell you what
email is if you don't know?
And I remembered-- sort
of from being there,
I knew that Dartmouth
had more of a history.
So that was sort
of the first place
that I started when
I said, I think
I want to write a very
different history than most.
Even among professional
historians,
most computing
histories are very
much like men and machines,
and that's changing recently,
but it wasn't the history
that I wanted to write.
And the final, the third
thing-- and I sort of
recommend everyone in
life go check this out.
There's a great book
called "Computer Lib:
You Can and Must
Understand Computers Now,"
written by Ted Nelson.
I think he self-publishes
it in 1974.
And in the first few pages
of that book, he has a map.
It's a hand drawn map.
And it's like, where
it's at, computing USA.
And I looked at that
map, and yeah, there's
MIT and the 128 area.
And of course, there's like the
Bay Area and a few other places
that I knew.
But then, I saw
Dartmouth and I thought,
haha, I'm onto something here.
And I saw Minnesota
and I saw PLATO,
and those were sort of
points for me to say,
what's going on there?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you had
some really interesting
looks back at history and
how gender and computing
interplayed.
And you touched on
it a little bit,
but I was curious if you had
more information about how
race and computing
interplayed back then
and how that's
changed over time.
JOY LISI RANKIN: Thank you.
That's a great
question, and it's
something I talk a little
bit about in the book.
For example-- and I'll use
the Dartmouth case again.
So at this time, Dartmouth--
in the early 60s, Dartmouth
has almost exclusively white
students.
And by the end of the 1960s,
as Kemeny becomes president,
they're working hard to
actively sort of recruit
and diversify Native
American students as well
as black students.
And there's this moment in time
where as all of these students
are coming in, you can
see in the newsletter
that they're giving to all the
first year students they're
promoting sort of
homegrown programs
about race that had been
developed to sort of combat
racism and to really sort
of make people aware of some
of the problems with racism.
But those programs, which had
been developed in anthropology,
they sort of came with
the warnings that said,
like, we don't recommend
the use of these programs
outside of classes for
advanced undergraduates
because they could
be misunderstood
if used the wrong way.
And meanwhile, the computing
center is like, "Hey,
all you first years.
Check out these programs."
And they're, I think
with all good intentions,
inadvertently
reinscribing the racism,
as well as calling attention to
the otherness of all of those
students who aren't
white men and really--
and this also sort of
needs to be emphasized--
doing work of saying, oh, well,
computing is something we--
race is something we can
study with computing.
Therefore, it's
separate from computing,
or it seems separate
from computing,
when we know that's
not the case,
when race, just
as much as gender,
is part of the social
world of technology.
AUDIENCE: It's not
a question, but it's
a little bit of optimism.
One of my markers for the
relationship between technology
and society is something
that I learned from Google.
If you do an image search for
scientist, even up to a year
ago, it was all pale males.
And I just did it just now.
I break my rule about opening
my laptops in a meeting.
And I checked, and
it's much better now.
So that's a positive note there.
Someone's working on it.
And the power of a
Google image search
to impact people's view of
a field is very important.
And so there's a
happy note there.
JOY LISI RANKIN: No, absolutely.
There is a happy note.
I mean, it's sort of--
it cuts both ways, right?
It's the artificial
intelligence and machine
learning saying if you asked
for a picture of a doctor,
you get a man.
If you ask for a picture of
a nurse, you get a woman.
But my colleagues
and I and people
here call attention to those
things and sort of increasingly
become aware of
the responsibility
that needs to be inherent.
And, like I said, the fact
that tech isn't separate.
Like, you're always
doing what you
do with people in mind
and to be more mindful
of who those people are.
You know, it can
make a difference.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Baby steps.
JOY LISI RANKIN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I thought it was
interesting you brought up
the fixation on pipeline
today as, I would call it,
a scapegoat from, you know,
actually doing something
about inclusively with
the people who are already
in the pipeline or
something like that.
And it strikes me
that that's not
an excuse you can use
in early computing.
Do you find that there were
similar scapegoat-y type
arguments in early computing
that limited diversity
and inclusion, or
was it more direct
and stereotyped in
the ways that you saw?
JOY LISI RANKIN: So I'm going to
summarize a lot of history here
and the work of my colleagues
to say-- so computers used
to be a word that meant people.
Pre World War II,
computers referred
to people who did mathematical,
arithmetic computations,
and those people were
most often women.
And when computing, certainly
in the United States, as well as
Great Britain--
sort of when computing
became in the, we'll
say sort of World War
I, World War II era,
the work of business
administration office machines,
people doing computing at that
time were most often women.
And it's why, in some
ways, it's not surprising
that there are so many women
doing computing in the United
States during the
1950s and 1960s.
What we've seen happen is that
as it was increasingly clear
that computers would be crucial
to society and valuable work,
sort of multiple
processes happen whereby
women were pushed out because
the work became work seen
as more prestigious,
and therefore,
as computing professionalized,
became a more masculine field.
So sort of aptitude
tests were given
for programmers that
really emphasized
masculine male
characteristics, for instance.
So it wasn't sort of--
in some ways, it was like
a reverse of inclusivity
where the women were
over time pushed out
and the cultures
around technology
became more masculine
in ways that it
was harder for them to be
in that work in that world.
JEREMY HYLTON: We
have time for one more
question, if there is one.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is related to the
previous questions.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
you see the role of
allyship is in closing some
of these opportunity gaps
for minorities in tech,
both in the past and maybe
presently, if you have time.
JOY LISI RANKIN: Yeah.
Thank you.
So I think being an ally
is crucial at this moment
to recognize sort of for all
of the people who are here
around Google and
other companies
that we identify as tech
companies to sort of really
do sort of individual and
communal self-examination
to say, what are the behaviors
or ideas or our cultures
in a particular meeting,
on a particular team?
How might those be--
how might those be not
just sort of in some ways,
being harmful to people
who are not like you,
but also, how might they
be amplifying privilege
or sort of just creating
more comfort for people
who are like you?
So I really do think it's
this ongoing level of saying,
"OK, I'm here, and I
want to be an ally.
I want to help support
and hire and work with
and empower people who
aren't like me to enhance
more diversity,"
whether it's gender
or race or sexual identity.
Sort of all the things.
But it's really a level
of awareness of both.
It's that sort of-- it's
the imaginary user, right?
And not just the imaginary
user of technology,
but in meetings, in spaces,
in corporate worlds,
as well as sort of the worlds
created by the technology
that we used.
SPEAKER: Thank you very much.
Again, Dr. Rankin.
Professor Rankin.
Joy.
JOY LISI RANKIN:
Any of those work.
SPEAKER: And Jeremy
for moderating.
We are wrapping up our
talk, but for all of you
here, we have copies of the
book that will be signed.
So I encourage you to come
and avail yourself of that.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]